how are the slopes of two parallel lines
related take these two parallel lines
for example if the slope of this line is
m1 and that of this one is m2 then how
are m1 and m2 related you don't really
have to think here it's obvious the tilt
or the inclination is the same m1 will
be equal to m2 the slopes of parallel
lines are the same okay great
so how are the slopes of two lines that
are perpendicular to each other related
take these two lines for instance assume
their slopes are m3 and m4 this may not
be obvious but the product of their
slopes is minus 1 m 3 times m4 is equal
to minus 1 another fancy way to say it
would be that they are negative
reciprocals of each other
m3 will equal minus 1 over m fo and m4
will equal minus 1 / m3 if lines are
parallel their slopes are equal and if
they are perpendicular and the product
of their slopes is minus 1 in this
example we are given the coordinates of
a and B and have been asked to find the
equation of the perpendicular bisector
of a B pause the video and try finding
the equation first let's plot the two
points on the coordinate plane 3 comma
minus 1 will be here and 1 comma 3 will
be this point let's join points a and B
it's perpendicular bisector will look a
bit like this let's call it CD CD is
perpendicular to a B and it will also
bisect a B now we've been asked to find
the equation of this blue line the
equation of line CD with the slope
intercept form let's assume that it's
equation is y
is equal to MX plus B how do we find the
equation we need m and B M is the slope
of CD and B is its y-intercept how can
we find the slope of CD to find the
slope of any line we need the
coordinates of at least two of its
points we have the coordinates of a and
B which can give us the slope of a B and
as a B and C D are perpendicular the
slope of a B will give us the slope of C
D their product will equal minus one so
we will have M now how do we find B
which is the y-intercept
look at the slope-intercept form if we
have M then we just need the coordinates
of one point on CD to find B because
then we can substitute the coordinates
in place of x and y and get be the only
point at which we can find the
coordinates is this one the intersection
of a B and C D because it is also a
midpoint of a B and we can easily find
the midpoint of a B as we have the
coordinates of its endpoints so after we
get the slope of C D we find the
midpoint of a B which will also give us
B once we have M and B we can easily
find the equation of C D okay
so what is the slope of a B it will be
minus 1 minus 3 over 3 minus 1
difference of y-coordinates over the
difference of x-coordinates this gives
us minus 2 the slope of a B is minus 2
now we find the slope of CD as a B and C
D are perpendicular the product of the
slopes will be minus 1 so minus 2 times
M will equal minus 1 slope of a B times
the slope of CD equals minus 1 we get
the slope of CD as 1 over 2 now we get
to the midpoint of a B the X
coordinate of the midpoint is the
average of the x-coordinates of the
endpoints the x-coordinate will be 3
plus 1 over 2 and the y coordinate of
the midpoint will be minus 1 plus 3 over
2 2 comma 1 will be the midpoint of a B
and it is also one of the points on C D
so we can substitute these values in
place of x and y substituting the values
of M x and y here we get 1 equals 1/2
times 2 plus B solving this we get the
value of B as 0 M is 1/2 and B is 0 the
equation of line CD will be y is equal
to x over 2 this video was a bit taxing
I'm sure if you haven't understood it
well make sure you go through it again
I'm sure it will make more sense